hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm about to make a mistake I
figured out how to ignore that I don't
think he'll get me if I don't go to the
door so I think I'm fine for now but I'm
gonna make a mistake because I figured
out how to get friends here I'm about to
make a post saying that I want people to
be my friend I don't know what this is
going to do but this is a big part of
how animatronics are sent between
peoples you get a friend requesting them
when they have animatronics they can
send it to you so we're gonna find out
on my regret this but feel free to send
as many animatronics as you want my way
I think that's the right QR code if not
it's going somewhere fun all right let's
see what Wow magic I'm in a different
shirt now that's so weird huh almost
like it's a completely different day but
that wouldn't be the case unless I lost
all the recording which would be a
tragedy if that happened and I'd be
super sad because I hope I did I played
for like an hour and a half the who
who'd suck if all that footage just went
away up into the air poof
I still here's the deal the whole
recording wirelessly thing didn't work
out I'm recording differently but it's
also just as likely that it'll go wrong
so I don't know I also tried hooking it
up wired and I was gonna do wired but if
you're listening here you can't record
the audio there so it's almost like
there's no point because there's no
headphone jack in here because Wireless
is the way of the future
so I'm gonna catch you up on what
happened that you guys did not see okay
you may notice I've got chica here also
you may notice I've got so many friends
it doesn't load brother I mean I know
this looks like I have no friends but
trust me when I say I've got so many
friends that the system just breaks
because of how many friends I have this
is blank why is it blank
I'm not connect to the Internet why okay
hang on guys it's been a long day been a
long day been a long day been a long day
okay so now now I can show you how many
friends I have there I've got there see
see I've got so many friends it lags out
the entire system I've got friends out
the ass I've got friends and friends and
friends and friends and friends and
friends and friends and
and friends and the good thing about
having friends is that they can send
animatronics your way now I don't know
if people are already
wait let me actually recall hey you're
fine good job I don't know what you did
you all right
hey you're okay oh okay so yes having
lots of friends means having lots of
animatronics so now we're gonna get back
into the game because I almost got a
streak of nine my max streak as it says
right up there is eight and when you get
nine you get another animatronic slot so
I'm going for the big nine where you at
buddy boo who is it this time oh oh
hello
no I don't remember what the flashlight
does exactly I should probably look up
the mechanics of this game of price
decide - wait Oh - that was a really
slow reaction but you know that's okay
okay i won
it's just that easy everybody but when
it comes down to being awesome at games
that's just natural when it comes to me
that sentence made sense fine so if I
can get woo well I guess we're all ready
to go it's I don't know if there's a
notification if I'd go online for my
friends but I think they just always
perpetually have an amateur omos pointed
it in my general direction which is yo
it's flattering I'm flattered
is what I'm trying to say I'm big
flattered god damn it I'm not not always
ready for that oh hi I'm not always
ready for you either there have there
are some other animatronics besides bear
endoskeletons that will come my way I
fought a few of them and I won I want to
all right okay you're over there oh I
think he was gonna uncloak anyway I'm
pretty sure that one was gonna uncloak
well hey a wins a win so I ain't gonna
complain too much about it you're over
there somewhere you getting something
out of my mini-fridge yo if you just
asked you could have gotten a drink I
don't mind uh plenty of it to go around
it ain't gonna be wait where is he wait
what the hell what okay so it does
nothing the flashlight does nothing
what's the point in the flashlight then
what does the flashlight do I think the
trick is to always stay mobile because
just in case there bring it out like
that like that you can move away from
him so you got to stay nice and mobile
you got to stay nice and loosey-goosey
that's what I gotta say you got to keep
the hips on a swivel if you want to be
able to survive in this nightmare that
really looked like he was about to deep
Lok and you think that if I SAP
electricity in that general direction it
would still get whoever was deciding
than they needed to go down my gullet at
that given moment but yeah what do I
know I'm an idiot
Joyce I'm sorry I was trying to do a lot
of things when you get interference you
gotta shake it but I guess there's a P
that still works - wait no I just want
that should be three what what that
should be three I wonder if the street
goes down every time you like back out
cuz that also might be the thing like
you have to do it all in one one sesh
I'm ready for crazy
I know crazy here no crazy here whoa oh
it was crazy but it was in the wrong
place
well you wasted your opportunity there
buddy boo he thought I was over there
but it turns out I was not really you're
gonna waste my time like that you're
gonna waste mine annual okay all right
you can't waste my time you can waste my
time if you want oh hey you're being
silly and sweet easy
bye-bye whoo God this is what happens
when you just got too many friends
they're always ringing your doorbell
trying to hang out trying to have fun
cuz that's what this is all about having
fun you know if the lights were out this
way just I was wait a minute this
endoskeletons a little funky if my
lights were out this would be a lot
creepier but good thing I'm not gonna do
that
oh god I should hit it boy what is it
gonna be like it's my legs out what what
happens oh it's it's much darker in here
Milas is dark yeah okay let's do this
you know it's fine it's good okay okay
all right I can handle a little spook I
can handle a little bit of spewpa ch I'm
not too worried about that thank you
Oh God that just in time whoa
what the hell
Oh what the hell is that what the hell
is that
oh I've never heard that before in my
life
the squeaky feedback thing I've never
heard that all right oh oh you're gonna
be sassy are ya oh yeah come on we're
gonna freak out you're gonna freak out I
bet you are
I bet you are or are you
what is that oh okay oh it's Bonnie
fascinating that's really fascinating
Bonnie
bonbon hey Barney boo whoa what was that
okay all right bonbon
all right blonde boy all right okay Oh
oh my god ooh okay
you are over here you liked being behind
me you like the back of the room I get
that
Oh way to go what is uh toughy oh I
don't like my lights being on I'll use
it toffee ancient or use a widow toffee
okay
all right cool Oh God
this is a prolonged battle oh hey how
you doing there
I get it okay okay good
he should warn you no quarter for ya
it's the whole crew ain't it
next you're gonna tell me that Freddie's
gonna be on his way
whoa you are so fun
I like you where'd you go oh there you
two where'd you go come on
it's weird cuz I okay all right so
you're freaky you're free to you okay so
good news good news your freaky all
right you know that makes two of us whoa
all right I'm just trying to keep the
camera low I saw that
keep the camera a little bit mobile so
that I can be ready just in case there's
a bra before you ask yes the leg swing
was necessary
I needed to generate the proper momentum
sure do like my desk over there yes I
know see I don't know if I'm like just
barely cutting it with that what oh god
I never I never would have made it I
never would have made it flapping my
gums over here okay laughing chuckle
nuts well you lied cuz I would have had
you're dead dead on right dead sight
dead sights
Oh God just just and mate
ha he's not making it easy is not making
it easy
oh yeah oh yeah alright in the gullet oh
do you hate to see it
are you hate to see it except that I
love to see it and I want to see more of
that a crashed and I lost that footage
nice going great the lights are off the
gloves are off I'm ready to punch
literally everybody in the face I'm
gonna keep punching
all the animatronics until they just go
away and die that's my goal that's the
end goal here see you're this ah my
first visitor I can't wait to be
thrashed by an animatronic ording
whichever fails me first
alright come on I gotta build my streak
all the way back up you don't want to
show yourself to me
um very handsome Oh think that you get
to just do that to me no no no just
because I'm a little bit distracted
given that I've had some problems does
not mean that I'm gonna let you get me
with such an easy spook no no no no no
no way no how
that's my shadow by the way the dick
right in the
back to one baby my sweet streak is it
is can't be beat is my lavalier
microphone recording yes it is I am good
Yaga God leave a like for all my
troubles subscribe for more quality
top-notch youtuber content from a person
he's been doing this for seven years and
still can't record things right alright
enough of me blabbering on about how
I've got problems
I've got animatronic shock come on who
do we got did you lose or ibly there is
no chance I am always going to win tiny
baby Oh God I I don't know why that got
me so bad I have no idea why I have no
excuse for that one oh it's just an
embarrassment for everyone involved at
least they're being nice and they're
getting near quick they're getting
you're quick and then they're leaving
quick so long as they keep doing that we
ain't gonna have a problem just let me
get my bread oh is that Barney again I
just got you so if you think that you
could go
I have no excuse for those I can't
really defend anything I can't really
defend anything that's quite
embarrassing that's another one I'm
getting closer three more three more and
then I'm there three more three more
guys three more you go get in here
you're gonna get you shocked and then
you're gonna go home to whoever owns you
you're gonna go home cried with your
tail between your lap I get that I get
that sorry called you out on something
personal I get that you'd be upset not
everyone can have a tail oh oh oh no
wait that's it
two more that's all I need just two more
no no no it is you it is you who is
gonna suffer suffer at the hands of my
enormous hands my big strong hands
wrapped around your endoskeleton neck
although I don't think you almost got me
you tricked me
I tried to trick me it tried to trick me
I will not be tricked I'm on trickable
which one more one more baby one more
one more baby come on do it what are you
gonna do if you guys do whatever you
gonna do what we gonna do you're
somewhere here where the hell are you
[Applause]
boom hi I did it honey okay let's keep
going let's keep going let's keep going
if I can get to 13 I get another slot oh
here we go
funny thing about that is kind of dead
I'm always ready for Friday it's hard to
see with the lights off but I got you
okay fine okay it's fine Oh God all
right so I've got more annamund troll
mows I'm gonna send you to one of my
many many friends of which I have many
many many many friends nope there's no
friends here because I've got too many
friends my game is never gonna be the
same because I've got so many friends
yeah they are a scary baby
or not oh I've got too many friends
I can't even send an intimate Rover to
attack someone
cuz I've got about eight friends oh I
can't even get out of the old things
crashing great oh no there we go
attacking okay good good good good
ah okay I'm gonna end this one here
because I I think I've still got the
recording here from this one so I'm
assuming that all the technical sure
your mouth I'm assuming that all the
technical difficulties have been I'm
blind I'm Suman that all the technical
difficulties have been taken care of
which means that we are finally good
from everything I'm looking at looks
good oh sorry looks good dummy looks
good baby okay so thank you everybody so
much for watching this has been a bit of
an endeavor but this game is fun my
problem with it is just trying to get it
to record properly which is not
something that you guys need to concern
yourselves with so what I want is to
break it even further I want to see how
broken I can make this game by getting
way too many friends
so if you want to be my friend I'm
putting a link right there in the top
line of the description you can click on
that it'll take you to a page where it
can send you the link or there's a QR
code you can scan to be my friend
destroy my life with animatronics make
it so that it's almost unplayable how
many people are trying animatronics to
be friendly and have fun with me but
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you enjoyed this video leave a like
if you want to see more videos like this
subscribe and ring the bell to be
notified whenever I've got new content
coming your way and if you want to see
more five nights at Freddy's shut up
there's a link in the description and
there's videos in the suggestion videos
up over there so thank you everybody
again and as always see you
[Music]